c'est le projet d'une passion entre une
mère et sa fille anita et sarah berdugo
ont écrit et dessiné ensemble pourquoi
tu pleures
un album pour enfants ce livre réalisé
pendant leur temps libre et le second
projet mené par le duo familial
cette fois ci c'est les larmes c'était
un symptômes physiques
c'est un sujet qui est encore tabou dans
notre société les gens s'autorise pas
forcément à pleurer et donc on a voulu
expliquer qu' il ya mille et une raisons
de pleurer pas seulement quand on est
tristes ou quand on s'est fait mal
destinée aux enfants de 2 à 6 ans
l'album a pour but d'ouvrir la
discussion entre l'adulte et l'enfant
pour lui apprendre à ne pas refouler ses
larmes
c'est très important pour nous deux que
l'enfant n'est pas de genre particulier
pour bien montrer que c'est une fille ou
un garçon ou n'importe quoi d'autre
déjà c'est pareil un côté un peu
universelle en fait de l'humain et
l'objectif c'est une pose la question
pourquoi tu pleures
en fait pour que l'enfant lui-même
puisse prendre la parole et raconter sa
propre expérience
anita et sarah espère avoir autant de
succès que pour leur premier livre le
jardin intérieur de l'est a fondu en
plusieurs centaines d'exemplaires
touchant même d'autres pays francophones
une campagne de financement ulule a été
mis en place afin de soutenir le projet
anita est aidé par deux stagiaires pour
alimenter les différents réseaux sociaux
on a pour objectif aussi dans le cadre
d'une campagne réussie de pouvoir donner
nos livres dans les hôpitaux pour
enfants parisiens à l'hôpital trousseau
l'hôpital necker et l'hôpital robert
debré afin que les enfants hospitalisés
puissent avoir accès à ce monde des
émotions
les objectifs initiaux de vendre 80
exemplaires ont d'ores et déjà été
atteint mais la campagne s'arrêtant le
15 décembre un état et sarah ou bien
l'ambition de vendre encore de nombreux
albums